ce rendez vous était celui d'un
faire-part pour les syndicats ce
vendredi midi à besançon avec l' annonce
du décès programmée de la justice une
minute de silence à d'ailleurs été
observée à cet effet le projet de fusion
des tribunaux de grande instance et des
tribunaux d'instance ne passe pas son
temps grève on nous parle dans le cadre
de ce projet de loi par l'article 56
c'est un peu technique mais c'est
important pour nous du fait qu'on va
créer des pôles de juridiction cour
d'appel tribunaux de grande instance
fusion des tribunaux d'instance et
l'ultra et des tribunaux d'instance et
tout cela veut dire que le justiciable
est coupé sa justice et c'est en cela
qu'on manifeste aujourd'hui outre la
disparition de la proximité des moyens
humains et financiers
les syndicats évoquent également la
privatisation de la justice
cette loi a pour objectif de faire des
économies et donc notamment en
privatisant
la justice civile pour certains actes le
justiciable ne devra payer par exemple
pour la vérification des comptes de
tutelle qui sont actuellement donc
vérifier au tribunal cette vérification
sera transmise à des intermédiaires des
intervenants privés
les syndicats annoncent la suppression
future en france 2 307 tribunaux
d'instance
une manifestation nationale est prévue
le 11 avril prochain